illuminate the world to the point where
you feel like you're really there and
thanks to the xbox series x and s ray
tracing is utilized in forza vista to
really make our cars look more true to
real life
you'll encounter the smallest of details
as you travel throughout the world all
rendered within striking realism oh
that's such an exciting overview i
cannot wait and next up is something we
know that force horizon fans have
definitely been waiting for the most
mike what exactly is that
yeah that's right we are about to reveal
the cover of forza horizon 5 featuring
the incredible mercedes amg 1 and the
2021 ford bronco badlands should we take
a look
[Music]
roof
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now those are two very different ways to
explore mexico so what i want to know is
why those two cars were chosen and what
players can expect when they get behind
the wheel
yeah so those differences are exactly
why we chose them the mercedes amg one
marks the first time a car features
formula one hybrid technology almost to
one from track to the street and with
the 2021 ford bronco badlands um you
know that's primed for rugged
off-roading across mexico's best terrain
and i'm certain people can't wait to see
more of what these cars can do in the
game so i don't think we should keep
them waiting any longer mike can you
tell us about what we're about to see
next yes so in a few moments time we'll
be kicking off a forza horizon 5 let's
go stream and everyone should check that
out for a big deep dive into loads of
new content and features from forza
horizon 5.
but before that we have eight minutes of
brand new gameplay where we're gonna see
both the mercedes amg one and the 2021
ford bronco badlands and in typical
horizon fashion we are going to see
active volcanoes cars jumping out of
cargo planes and a race under beautiful
mexican skies all the way to the horizon
festival
should we check out i think we should
here we take control of the 2021 ford
bronco badlands atop the towering
snow-capped grand caldera volcano
card
okay
there might be a little bit of traffic
ahead what's up with that
making new friends hey
you go enjoy yourself i have to go make
another delivery
[Music]
stop zone approaching
lovely day for us right
[Applause]
so now we see the 2020 corvette stingray
tearing up asphalt towards a dust storm
in the mexican farmland
i'll track the storm
keep going
[Music]
[Music]
these
okay
there's no other way around we've got to
go through it
for the eye of the storm
[Music]
um
this could get a little rough
[Music]
touchdown not even a scratch the jungle
awaits
next up is the porsche 911 desert flyer
crashing through the dense jungle tree
canopy flamingos
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
feel so
[Music]
guide you through the bridge
you're not gonna believe your eyes when
you see this keep going
[Applause]
this is the final drop the whole
festival is waiting
go go go
what do you say
first of the
and on the final leg we have the
stunning mercedes amg one at full speed
across mexico's sun-baked rocky coast
horizon this is
mexico we've already had cars falling
out of the sky but all eyes are on the
superstar making their way to the
festival right now
[Music]
if you've just arrived and arrived in
mexico then you are in for a treat my
friends
get ready for the biggest horizon
adventure of your life
did you hear that well that is the last
inbound cargo fight racing neck and neck
with an amg one
[Music]
so strap yourself in horizon
i've seen this driver before
[Music]
so
[Music]
well that was absolutely incredible and
i know i for sure will never get tired
of cars parachuting out of planes
anytime soon but i am going to need a
minute to process all the amazing
gameplay we just watched which works out
just fine because we need to welcome
everyone who just is joining us right
now so for those of you who just turned
up we have just wrapped the gamescom
2021 xbox stream and have so much more
content to cover so please sit back and
enjoy our latest episode of forza
horizon 5 let's go live with playground
games we have an excellent show coming
your way so first in case you missed it
we're going to be recapping the major
gamescom announcements from just a few
moments ago as well as taking a closer
look at the forza horizon 5 limited
edition xbox wireless controller and the
initial drive gameplay
then we'll take the freshly announced
cover cars for a bit of a spin and debut
a brand new showcase event as well as a
few more cars along the way
so
mike and don that was all very very
exciting but i think first of all we
need to talk a bit more about the
controller because wow what a statement
can you tell us a little bit more about
how it came to be yes so uh this is it
this is the
five limited edition xbox or wireless
controller to give its full title um
yeah so it was probably around about
over 18 months ago now wasn't it the
hardware team approached us and said
they really wanted to uh produce limited
edition controller for thoughts of
horizon five and obviously we were like
yes absolutely um
we really love how it's come together it
brings so much vibrancy and color it
just feels like it's a little piece of
the horizon festival that's like plopped
out of the screen and landed in your lap
uh loads of cool features as well those
are little like kind of hidden easter
eggs uh yeah it's been great right yeah
it's been awesome and i think
integrating the stuff that we've seen in
the initial drive with the the powder
explosions and and the colors on on the
car um on the cargo plane and and
whatnot i mean integrating that into the
controller has been a lot of fun and for
anyone else who maybe didn't pick up on
camera but the controller is also
translucent as well which i get really
nerdy over translucent controllers so i
just want in case anyone missed that
detail it is and there is an additional
detail as well because it also comes
with some exclusive car dlc right it
does it does yeah um so while we're on
the translucency it has a forza logo
inside it and this thing down here is
like brightly colored so did you miss
that so thank you there you go should we
uh roll the vt on the video yeah so
those people who purchase the controller
will also get some exclusive dlc uh part
of that is the forza edition ford coupe
uh which is this amazing car right here
looks absolutely a real eye-catcher just
like the controller uh you can see the
paint job on there as well is inspired
by the controller so it will um it will
match you can match out the game and in
the game love it as we see here as well
um
because it's got that exposed engine uh
you really it really takes advantage of
all the radio reflections that we've got
going on here on here in forza vista
you get a couple other things as well
you get a character cosmetic and an
emote so that uh when you win win an
event in your exclusive uh focus you can
let people know you do you can control
that exactly
you can really rub it in now i know we
announced it on the xbox show but to
confirm when can people pre-order and
get their hands on it uh i believe it
might be up for pre-order now on the
microsoft store yeah if not now then
very very soon and other retailers
shortly after that but i think
yeah if you want one now then jump over
to the microsoft store perfect right
well while you go do that um let's talk
a little bit more about the initial
drive game play which we just saw and is
for context the very first game play
players will see when they experience
forge horizon 5. so what was that like i
imagine it's a huge deal finally showing
people that part of the game
uh absolutely yeah it's it's a it's a
part of the game that we probably spend
the most time working on the initial
kind of opening 10 minutes or so um it's
it really we want to make a statement
and then set out what what forza horizon
5 is what it's going to offer what great
things you're going to experience over
the rest of the game but condense down
into a in that instance and an eight
minute run um so you see loads of the
world you see different cars different
driving experiences it just gives you
that real like buffet of flavors that
the game will offer later on
yes yeah it was really it was really a
challenge to try to show as much as we
we wanted to show um without showing
everything and fitting in within you
know the
the nice eight minute the time that we
wanted for the initial drive i love it
so we're actually going to take a quick
look back at the highlights of that
gameplay in case you missed it so let's
take it away
is
[Applause]
so
[Music]
or no that's fine
touchdown not even a scratch
[Music]
[Music]
this
festival is waiting
they know
and that's that's the start of the game
so you do your initial drive after all
the adrenaline floods through you after
that you actually then get to select
your first car which is what we are now
looking at at the moment so can you talk
us through the cars that we have on the
smorgasbord right now and why they're
here as well why do we go for these
three our second smorgasbord in 20
minutes i'm going to say it five more
times you can count right i feel like it
just decided to add it
keep track in the chat if charlie does
it
um so yeah so these are the three cars
you can choose from at the start of the
game uh first up is the chevrolet
chevrolet c8 corvette um
the car looks absolutely stunning uh the
insane grip that it manages to hold
means is like a really great car to
start the game it allows you to go super
super fast um but it basically never
breaks traction
um
next up we have the ford bronco one of
our cover cars
basically the hottest suv of the year
and then a car that i would say needs no
introduction but we gave it a pretty
cool introduction uh two weeks ago on
the previous let's go stream but yes it
is the 2020 toyota supra gr
um
one interesting point about uh about the
car selecting this game in previous
horizons we had a similar layout of cars
at the start of the game um but you can
only pick one it was a bit like choosing
your your starter pokemon um this time
whichever one you pick actually all
three get added to your garage so
whether you pick the super the bronco or
the covet that is only a decision that
you have to live with the consequences
of for as long as you want to stay in
that car as the other ones will be in
your garage and go jump into them
whenever you like wonderful
so we are going with the bronco first
choice and here we go
letting it all soak in this is so
exciting what a huge moment this is when
you start a forza game as well
is probably where i spend the most time
just picking my license plate name
even though i know i could change it
later it's just oh absolutely it still
feels like it's it's a decision of
consequence isn't it
and andy going with the default
he didn't force us all to sit here
watching him uh
select his name
i guess we should intro andy
yeah so for anyone wondering you will
hear an additional voice on stream today
and that is the wonderful andy who is
going to be playing uh actually doing
the gameplay today but we decided we
didn't want him on camera so he's just
he just sat off to the side he looks
excellent if anyone's even gonna get a
sneak peek of him at some point yeah
yeah baby steps yeah work my way up to
being okay you'll be on the sofa next
time we promise
it's okay so we've picked the car we fit
the license plate we're going to our
first showcase event
what is this going to be talk us through
what we're about to drive up to
yeah so we've taken part in the initial
drive where we've just seen uh four
separate cars drop out of the back of a
cargo plane and we
next let's go race against that cargo
plane and so this is a showcase event in
which uh we will take on that cargo
plane perfect and we're also hearing
some characters talking during this
drive as well who were they do we
recognize them are they new
um the voice you can hear right now is a
scott tyler the only character to have
appeared in all all five horizon games
uh he is our resident dj on horizon base
arena um he's also the hype man uh
at the festival
um and in this instance if i wasn't
talking over it you'd have heard him
saying that he's
he he's just been pulled off mike you've
been dragged out of the uh dragged out
the booth for a reason that might become
obvious in just a few minutes time
uh we're also in in millah now as well
right yeah we're in mulhee which is this
very uh this town that's right in the
middle of the living desert um
very uh nice charming town
and just outside the town is uh some
festival goers what are they doing here
yeah
i'm really excited this i won't lie to
you there's something there's something
so exhilarating about the showcases i
can't wait to see this what's it like
actually making a showcase especially
following the ones for me the ones that
resonate with me the most is forts
horizon four so how does how does that
compare to making five i imagine there's
an element of one upping yourself right
yeah
how do we do four again but bigger and
better i mean that that exact sentiment
applies to almost the entire game um and
it is uh absolutely a challenge and and
some people have said that we need to
stop treating that as a as a strategy
because we will reach a point where uh
we won't be able to one off ourselves
but um right now we feel like that is
future playground games problem and not
one that not one that we need to worry
about because uh i think this probably
is one of our most uh spectacular
showcases uh we've put together so far
andy actually designed this so andy are
our resident driver who um you may hear
the voice of very soon uh was actually
the level designer who put this showcase
together so uh if anybody can drive it
in a perfect fashion it will be him
yeah
it's also a new car isn't it andy yeah
yeah this is uh ken block's v2 escort
cosworth
uh it's an amazing car built with sort
of modern rally specs in mind with all
the aerodynamics and
insane group that those cars have these
days
and of course an amazing livery amazing
livery which has fallen horizon as well
which is lovely um yeah it's
it's not it's like 300 horsepower yeah i
think it's 370 horsepower okay 370. so
not crazy powerful but super lightweight
um
and can
can really move um because light as well
the brakes are awesome so even in some
of the tricky driving
maneuvers you'll have to pull in a
minute it is possible to slow down
really fast
yeah and uh and ken block's uh gymkhana
videos were a massive inspiration for me
as well oh wow what for the showcase
event
yeah
it was
something that i considered when i was
making it if um
if horizon was to make
one of the jim carter videos you know
what would we do
so that's the sort of uh
the lens
right
a plane becomes bikes
perfect timing right into guanajuato um
this is our main city in the game
and just like we've shown in uh you know
previous previous footage guanajuato is
like a super beautiful city with uh
uh undulate um undulating roads and an
underground uh tunnel network um there's
actually a mural right there by spake
one of the mural artists um our mexican
mural mural artist um and yeah i just
love the the color and the the
architecture the baroque and
neoclassical architecture in here um
there you go get a shot of the
guanojuato basilica
one of the most iconic buildings in all
of mexico wow it's stunning building
yeah it's storm has inhuman
look at the colours as well i will never
forget you said this to me on the street
previously of all the houses being
different shades and it's so gorgeous
and you can't have the same color house
next to each other
[Music]
i like that they all take in their own
little um off routes as well
and just sort of like coming out of
nowhere
yeah that's the thing about these
showcase opponents they will do anything
to win
um
always always up to tricks aren't they
andy
you've always got to keep keep the
players second guessing what's coming oh
absolutely
we're right up in the northern tip of
the map at the moment as well
so yeah we'll get a glimpse of the
canyon but we'll take a closer look
later
whoa
what happened there
so that bike knew he was beaten he knew
he didn't have a chance so he has uh he
has switched to a wing suit for the uh
the final stretch
oh very good he probably had his beat if
he was willing to face planet into the
road
you had to pull a shoot and you have to
make a choice at that point don't you
whether you want to win or whether you
want to survive the race
oh that was incredible can you give us
any more hints obviously the showcases
are so amazing can you give us any hints
of maybe other showcases that we've got
coming up or i don't know what you're
happy to say well i don't want to spoil
it we've still got so much more to talk
about uh we've got four showcases in the
game uh one that i am particularly
excited about is the train showcase and
we're gonna train showcases in every
horizon game but i think this time it
really is the the best train check ever
showcase we have ever done uh and i'm
really excited to show it off but that
is for another day i'm looking forward
to that so what are we going to look at
next i think we're going to start
talking about some of the cars and we're
starting with one in particular and that
is the bronco
um
yeah we came up with the broncos yeah so
we stopped we were we drove the broncos
to the showcase uh we are still in the
bronco now if the guys want to pick the
feedback up
um
so we're still still playing through the
the start of the game and haley one of
our characters has called us up and
asked us to head back to the festival
and obviously as you can see we are
still in the bronco uh perfect car for
so for chilling out on a nice nice
leisurely drive like this one but also a
perfect car for heading across the
desert or tearing it up through heading
towards that dust storm in the tower
heading towards the dust storm that is
also a totally valid option
and scent
is that engulfed the festival is those
the hot air balloons you can see just in
front of yes good good call actually
charlie so we've always put those hot
air balloons above the festival so that
often times you can't see the festival
because it might be quite low lying
versus your position but whenever you
see the higher balloons then you'll know
that it's one of the festival sites and
you can head over towards them so it
gives you that kind of vertical
notification that there's a really cool
thing you can explore that
i'd be worried if i was done with this
weather
about to get lost in that dust storm
a ticket for the day and you see that in
the distance
you can use your skills
every car has its own set offering
unique bonuses
skill points there's a very intimidating
costume the dust storm looming in the
background that is our first view of the
horizon festival i think the first time
we've uh we've shown it
it's my friend so what's haley talking
us through here then we've just revealed
something on the map
yes so still let's start the game um
we've completed that showcase event
we've headed back to the festival and
now uh haley is giving us the option of
taking one taking on one of these two
horizon stories okay so the one at the
bottom there with the vw badge is called
vocho where we'll team up with alejandra
who's one of our mexican characters and
to help her search for an abandoned a
lost abandoned car which is the beetle
and the mexican name for the beetle is
the vodcho
um the camera icon is a story called el
camino in which we will team up with a
mexican photographer called carmen and
we'll head out in this instance into the
storm so into that dust storm that we
could just see and take some awesome
photos inside the dust storm amazing um
both of those though are for a another
day i think oh i see we're not even
gonna do one of those all right then
another time another time
so what is it we're going to jump into
right now then i think we're going to
dip away i'm going to dip the feed
andy's going to do a quick quick car
swap and then we will take a better look
at the uh the amg one i think amg okay
so what can you tell us about the amg
while we're waiting to get it all set up
then so yeah so uh alongside the bronco
is our other cover car um and frankly
just one of the coolest most hottest
cars in the world right now absolutely
um it's
built by mercedes amg they've taken all
of the incredible technology from their
formula one cars and put it into a car
that is entirely road legal um and looks
absolutely incredible despite basically
having the performance of a formula one
car yeah yeah um
yeah it looks incredible doesn't it like
the shape of it is stunning
um the shark fin on there which
uh to me looks like that step purely to
show off but andy assures me that there
are real performance benefits to it
and there's this new icon right in the
bottom bottom right as well what's this
please explain what this is
so one of the um particularly awesome
things about this car um is when if you
were to purchase this car it comes with
a couple of modes it's quite common for
performance cars to have uh different
modes um but they don't oh oh okay sorry
mate um they don't always uh they're not
always as cool as this so on the on the
steering wheel there's a button that you
can press which swaps you from uh track
mode to street mode so if andy gives it
a click
um we're currently in track mode and
we'll transition to street mode so you
see those fins over the wheel arch close
the the spoiler dips down and the car
actually lowers oh sorry raises on its
suspension so if you need to get a speed
bump or pull up into your drive
then you might put into this mode um
it also kind of smooths out some of the
lines looks looks a bit sleeker um the
cool thing about that is you can just
click that button whenever and as you're
as you're driving around the world and
it really changes the performance of the
car as well i was about to ask what how
you would like actively use it in forza
actually like was there a sender drive
version of the car versus a race mode
uh that is literally what it is to be
honest
um this probably isn't the place that
that car mostly
um
but uh but yeah it kind of shows what
the car can do it's still a really
powerful awesome car and apparently is
perfectly drivable through a farm field
as you can tell we're in a new biome
that we haven't shown before which is
the mexican uh farm field which is i
guess farmland is is
a staple of horizon games uh by now um
and definitely for
uh for 2005 we have like some unique
mexican uh crops um which annie will
drive by
i think we saw um him driving through
some agave
um previously
what are we gonna go trash now what's
this so this these are mexican beans oh
yeah bean plants
got a rough harvest yeah
i think it's worth saying as well uh at
this doing sure that we are currently
looking at xbox series x gamepl
[Laughter]
more beans and here we have some uh
another crop sorghum and cool thing with
sorghum because it's so tall and you
could squash them you could actually
make some really awesome crop signs uh
in the fields they've messed up for the
players you could leave messages for
other players yeah
and contrary to what andy may have made
you believe there are actually roads
within the
land as well
a great car to just toot around
everywhere and just i don't know this
looks like my go-to sort of i'm just
gonna drive really fast over a hill and
get somewhere car
i think um
yeah right now we'll uh we'll cut away
and just do a little swivel we're on to
the next car ari okay so the next one
what's this what are we going to be
looking at
we are going to check out the
967 mark 1 ford escort so from going
from one of the
um hottest newest cars in the world
we're going to take a look at something
a little bit more of a classic motor
and there it is the uh
the mark one ford it's got an absolute
icon honestly um i think andy's going to
tell us a bit more about this one eddie
what's yeah what's cool about this uh
okay so this is a quite a fitting car
because this car took part in a rally in
1970
from the uk to mexico okay uh so i guess
a sort of a horizon to four to five
transition there um interestingly yes
that's a
16 000 mile rally
uh
across the world there and uh yeah and
this and this car won so it's based on
uh mark one escort rs 1600 which they
which they beefed up to handle all of
the uh all of the terrain that it would
it would have to handle across the world
uh and it did such a fantastic job
[Music]
those wheel arches are amazing aren't
they for the for the time they look they
look really kind of modern
yeah so the big bubble style rally
arches it's got uh on the front of it if
i try and not hit anything the big bull
bar
uh sort of rough bumper on the back as
well and the little individual lights
which are different to the factory car
as well
so everything just to make it you know
as easy to fix on the road as possible
and where is it that we're at now this
is over by the coast isn't it yeah so
we've just transitioned from farmland
through a little bit of jungle and now
we're at the actually at the tropical
coast um i think we'll do uh
another
uh car switch right now
oh wait look at that yeah
that's just as we get the feed we'll
look at that we'll take a look at that
in a second okay so up next is another
car and i this is going to be i'm going
to i'm going to say it another bronco
this is yeah yes this is another bronco
there are actually four separate
versions of the bronco in the game all
awesome all have their own uh own
personalities and reasons for being
there um
this one's a baja one isn't it andy this
is that's right
um yes we have obviously the bronco
badlands is on the cover we have the
classic 1975 bronco we have the bronco
ultra four which was actually in the
initial drive as well you kind of start
to jump over the porsche 911 in the
jungle section um
and then there's this one which is the
uh
andy please yeah
these people are on holiday
better look out
so yeah the tropical coast is is
definitely one uh compared to the west
um the rocky coast definitely like the
ideal
um
uh
kind of vacation destination you know
yeah the ideal uh visual you see when uh
thinking of mexico
anders
perfect postcard it does look at the
moment
if you're playing in storm season this
is one of the areas that can
when the weather conditions are right
can um have tropical storms which turn
it from this perfect paradise into a
really kind of like intense exciting and
visceral um like storm experience wow
a really cool thing to just drive drive
through
the idea of calling it a perfect
paradise after andy's been through yeah
[Music]
it's ironic in it i guess uh yeah we'll
do another another car change so many
car changes here so the next one where
are we going next what have we got
we have got the ford f-450 super duty
which is uh
a pretty exciting car for us as well
isn't it it's an absolutely massive
truck
it's a julie as well so it's got um it's
got four wheels on that back axle like
two wheels side by side each side um
means it's just got like
like ridiculous grunt in the back you
can go over any terrain and it's
absolutely massive
that is a big yeah
look at that
so what's that i mean to me that tells
me that's an off-road vehicle right i'm
trying to think like in a very sort of
way like what i would pick this car to
do like cross-country or those sort of
like off-road races right uh i think
certainly in the game uh that is
probably where you take it i think in
real life you'd probably
it could also be a a work truck or even
an everyday truck sure if you're a truck
person um
but yeah it's certainly it's it's got
that ford tough uh dna hasn't it yeah
it's built uh built for the road built
for off-road built for
doing your work in it yeah
chucking all your camping gear in the
back or a jet ski or something
everyone's camping gear in the back
hopefully we stumble upon one of our
ambient trucks or buses
around the world so you can see just how
big this thing is
it is a
6.7 liter diesel engine it's got a
thousand foot pound of torque which is
just
insane you could
pull your whole house along if you
wanted to
fit your house in the bed on the back
all that yeah
my little english houses through america
american view
[Music]
and where is it uh on the map are we at
the moment don so we are in the aired
hills which is perfect to show off the
the off-roading and uh power of this um
f-450
um
yeah we're in the art hills and there
hills is it's very kind of wild with
these
dense pockets of uh of trees um which
makes it really fun to um when you're
bee-lining across the world to kind of
just dodge some trees and hit some
smashable ones um so it's very engaging
experience for driving around and
obviously you see there's a bunch of
undulation as well um
the the aired hills actually sits
just outside of guanajuato so okay um
that's where why guanajuato is so
undulating because it's it's it's set
in a nest of hills
this is one of my favorite areas to uh
for eliminator
to grab grab a good offer a car with a
bit of suspension movement and then just
lurk around here and any
any unsuspecting car which doesn't have
that suspension movement can get getting
alive
um
i love the idea of you guys just having
like an afternoon where you all just set
each other in the eliminator that is
absolutely what we do that's friday
afternoon
love it is there any like unbeaten
champions at the moment
um
no no one's no there's not anyone
beating it's quite hard i think to stay
unbeaten and eliminated when there's so
many players
and then here we're transitioning into
the canyon the canyon biome and we
haven't seen the canyon yet either on
stream have we no we haven't seen it
since since the e3 demo yeah so yeah
it's uh
it's an absolutely
tried to park my house
[Laughter]
all right switch to it yeah we'll yeah
so we're going to go through the canyon
with another new car and what's this one
going to be
so we saw a few fords um now we're going
to check out the uh porsche mccann rally
raid
um
so this as you can see is a it's this
isn't uh a mccann as you would uh pick
it up from the showroom uh this is one
that's been built by lp racing as it
says on the back who are actually kind
of an aftermarket um
provider of motorcycle parts
for like really performance motorcycles
but they also have a motorsports arm
that do motorcycle racing and also uh
endurance car racing and this is one of
the cars that they've built for is it
for the baja
this is more sort of dakar
sorry um
yeah it's quite cool if the um the
escort mexico was the sort of 1960s
version this is the uh
this is the modern version of uh the go
anywhere endure everything racing style
the land rover defender just feeling
like he could go anywhere i think he saw
you in his rear view mirror yeah
i showed him how to do it
[Laughter]
so john what can you tell us about the
canyons as we go through it here yeah
gorgeous yeah so the canyon's really all
about scale and um just the impressive
rock cliff faces and kind of just
yeah
it's actually during sunset and sunrises
you get amazing sunlight so i know for
photographers it's a great um area to
get some photography
yeah because of those huge like rock
clip faces as well uh it's like one of
the best locations in the game to really
take advantage of the raytraced audio so
if you're in a car like this and you're
happy flying along next to next to this
rocky wall you can just hear the sound
of your engine like bouncing off the
wall
which really makes everything feel like
you're uh nestled in a real place
[Music]
sneak peek of the uh the train tracks as
well oh yeah
it just looks like a really fun place to
drive through it's like it because of
the hills it doesn't tell me there's a
lot of shortcuts over this area so
actually the type of place where you
just enjoy being on the road
yeah it's it it is right i said this is
one of the places where in real life
you'd go there just for the drive
exactly yeah you weren't actually going
anywhere you just drove there you drove
the roads and they were like let's drive
it back up a bit in nature
let's try a bit of off-road yeah
oh train track again there we go
you know where you going andy just about
i mean that's the great thing about the
canyon you have like a good off-road
experience plus you have a good on-road
experience as well
um
in parallel let's try and get back on
the road again
train track again don't stay there too
long again
all right and yeah we're gonna check out
uh another car yeah
oh yeah we've got one more to go through
and this is staying in the porsche
family this one isn't it now it is yes
so that one was the uh porsche macan
that was a purpose-built racing machine
this one is a car that
yeah it's not an everyday car but it's
one that normal people can purchase if
if they walked into a porsche dealer
unlike the
unlike the previous vehicles this is the
porsche taken turbo s which is porsche's
brand new performance electric vehicle
so actually the second electric car on
the stream today as well uh yes so the
amg one has is a hybrid so it's got an
electric motor this is 100 electric um
and it's it's a it's frankly a fantastic
car so the way the way porsche have
approached uh this with their very first
ev is they wanted to recreate the
driving experience of a 911 but in an
electric vehicle and that's especially
difficult because it obviously has to
have a massive battery and weighs about
2.4 tons
and despite that pretty incredible uh
weight it north 60s in 2.6 seconds top
speed 160. it's you know
um i haven't had the joy of driving one
unfortunately but uh apparently drives
basically just like a 911 which is a you
know fairly lightweight sports car
sorry sorry mate yeah
i know andy drives like me too
yeah i thought i was in the uk again
celebrity celebrity owners include uh
will smith oh and apparently someone
told me just before we came out bill
gates has one as well oh as you do yeah
so perhaps not the car for everybody but
it's uh
but maybe your dreams can one day come
true exactly exactly and if not forza
horizon 5 out in november play it then
great plug charlie remember remembering
why we're all here
like that little area on the corner
there so you've driven and does it does
it does it do it did it feel like a 911
oh absolutely
yeah
yeah incredible car
oh one thing i wanted to point out here
was butterflies
yeah so actually um in uh during a
certain season in mexico there's a big
monarch butterfly migration that happens
um in the canyon uh uh areas um so yeah
we kind of represented that in our game
as well this is such a stunning like
additional elements because it would
only be if you you go and stop here you
would see that because only people are
like bombing through it that's so
awesome i love it look at them all yeah
so you'll experience this in the spring
season um and then
um it won't be during spring obviously
but yeah
i think we wanted to drop one more
because there's one more bit we wanted
to show
i i don't know how to set this up what
do you guys want what are we going to do
now
so we actually revealed this car on uh
on social media last week and which
would be cool to give it a little
very very very brief run around this is
the sierra rx-3 um it's a utv so
super off-road vehicle um but also is
actually really high performance on
asphalt as well it can do both types of
racing incredible suspension travel if
andy wants to uh give it a whirl but
instantly
a lot of power going to the rear wheels
only so it's a bit of a
[Laughter]
yeah but there's just uh we're in the
air we're heading up into the arid hills
now which is just the uh i think the
perfect location to uh
to show some of the cool stuff that this
uh this particular car can do
as andy decides
all right and there we go amazing but
that's the very authentic thoughts
experience thank you so much andy right
well with that we're actually going to
move over to arguably one of my favorite
parts of the stream we are now going to
look at some community questions the
questions today are going to come from
chat so if you haven't typed a question
into chat yet make sure you do it now
and it might get answered on stream the
other half the first half are actually
going to come from twitter and your
social post where this week you asked
dia forza and what people wanted to know
so at first we've got a question from
fireheart561 who asks who's hayley and
what happened to kira
that can't be from twitter because we
only just revealed who hayley is on this
oh well that's about
that
so kira is still looking after the uh
festival in britain okay and she's still
in at the forza horizon 4 festival haley
is her good friend who is filling a
similar role at the mexico festival
she's one of the sure the first group of
horizon people who've arrived in mexico
to set up this new festival perfect
wonderful i've now dawned on me that
these questions are actually from chat
so if we keep that in mind going forward
and we'll forget the bit i just said uh
the next question comes from
mink wr who asks i have a question is
the game cross play so xbox users can
join pc users
yes um but uh
steam will function the same way foreign
forwarded so it won't be cross saved but
it will be cross play perfect wonderful
nice and simplistic right uh next
question comes from wolf sealers who
asked will we be able to toggle our cars
as a favorite uh yes yes you will that
will that it will function very similar
to how it did in forza horizon 4.
i love that it's just like a really
passionate community making sure that
all of their favorite features are still
there that's essentially what this
segment is i love it okay the next one
comes from
oof thank you uh who asks is there a
moving train on the map yes there is
we've we have mentioned it i don't know
if you want to give some more detail
while oof is in chat about the mat about
the train
don't you want
[Laughter]
track in the canyon there yeah we've
also mentioned that you will race
against it in the showcase event so yes
yeah very successful wonderful and the
final question from chat seems to come
from king shawn who simply asks is that
a supra yes sean it was a super back at
the
start of the stream uh yes we showed a
super in their initial contract and uh
that will be added to your garage at the
start of the game for everybody perfect
now these are the questions that did
actually come from social media and the
first one comes from forza horizon 5 uk
who asks will we get forza horizon
stories and if so how many so we've seen
a couple today but can you share any
more information uh yeah so we saw a
couple uh we saw varchar and we saw el
camino uh there are several more in the
game um we're gonna hold i'm gonna hold
fire on that one though and cover that
one in a later stream i think so yes the
horizon story is absolutely still uh an
important part of the game they're
bigger and better than ever before but i
think we'll cover that off in a later
stream lovely uh the next question comes
from rare gliscor one who says how
extensive is the tunnel system under
guanajuato and are there entrances to
the city from outside through those
tunnels
so there are no entrances through those
tunnels into the city but it is the most
extensive tunnel network uh in in the
game it's about two kilometers yeah wow
yeah so a lot of a lot of tunnel
wonderful uh scottish pancake ass dear
forza i love this this question is so
polite dear forza i do not know if
you've answered this question before but
but what seasons will be in forts
horizon five will they be the same as
sports horizon 4 or will there be
entirely new and different seasons
introduced to correlate with the new
setting that is a thorough question
which is a little room for maneuver
other than answering someone typed that
on social media that's the most eloquent
i've ever seen someone be on something
that's probably two tweets yeah
count the camera handle as well scottish
pancakes um so yes seasons are still
very much an important part of the game
i think we mentioned a few times about
different things you can see in
different seasons um we as as posed in
the question yes we have tried to
replicate the the seasonality of mexico
um we have in the game so in the game
it'll still say spring summer autumn
winter but then each one of them is is
suffixed with uh
a line that explains what it is in that
country so autumn is storm season winter
is dry season spring is hot season and
summer is wet season which allows people
from a temperate climate like i was in
europe or
in canada like don
to be like what even our seasons in
mexico i mean it kind of like right out
of the box it says like winter it's dry
season so you can kind of grasp straight
away and kind of get a feel for what
what it's going to be like there you
have hardly any rainfall at all
throughout the winter interesting
um yeah but weirdly though at the same
time
elevation they do get snow so we've seen
that on the volcano right yeah exactly
so high areas like on top of the volcano
you'll still get you'll still get snow
yeah i think it all it also helps you
let you know what season's next you know
the following week just having yes yeah
you know spring winter summer autumn
yeah wonderful so the next question
comes from cyrus luna who asks i think i
might be serious luna actually uh will
there be a drift adventure at launch
um yes there will sirius luna um so we
have it it won't be we've changed we'll
change multiple up a bit so it's not
online adventure anymore it's now called
the horizon open uh and you'll be able
to take on racing games drift or the
eliminator as part of that it's all been
reframed to be as accessible and easy to
get into it needs to have a lot of fun
in as possible perfect love that next
question comes from keisler who asks we
know about the new brake caliper
painting but will there be other
upgrades to the paint slash vinyl system
um yes so don jonah yeah so we reworked
a lot of how the vinyls and paint system
works um we streamlined it a lot um just
to give the users uh and players a lot
more
ease of use um so yeah a lot of
improvements there
and if you're on series s or x we've
also massively increased the resolution
of
of your of your car paints as well so
where you used to get like kind of fuzzy
lines around the edges of your decals
that will be much smoother now if you're
on a series of brilliant love that
next question what's the leveling system
like is it like three with a certain
number of levels or are we going to have
a prestige based leveling system like
four curious to know
um yes so we are going to cover the
campaign uh in more detail on the next
stream in two weeks time
um but uh of to answer the question more
directly it's the actual player leveling
system is more like thought to horizon
fours uh the campaign is quite different
though so we'll cover that off um in the
next stream one to watch if you want to
come back and watch that one uh next
question from um just
ask can you tell us more about the radio
stations um yeah so we actually heard a
bit of music didn't we earlier on
earlier on the show as part of the
initial drive we heard there were
actually original compositions for three
sections of the initial drive there from
uh from plague vendor in the uh farmland
section to luxury in the jungle section
and metric in the final section and
there's quite a few more original
compositions throughout the game where
we've contacted artists who typically
have been a part of horizon in the past
where we've licensed some of their music
and asked them if they could create
brand new pieces for us that are curated
to particular gameplay experiences
in terms of the radio station more
broadly uh we'll go into more detail now
on a future stream i think okay so i
want to know a lot about that as well so
i'll keep you posted on that um finally
i understand we have a question from a
celebrity uh our old friend tommy
bargains who asked i won't do the exit
uh they want to know i can't wait to
enjoy forza horizon 5. thank you tommy i
tried negotiating with playground games
to get super early access but they drive
a hard bargain is there a way i can
somehow feel the magic of forts horizon
5 in forza horizon 4 today um yes tommy
bargains yes there is that is a thing
that you can do so if you if you log
into fort horizon 4 now uh go over to
message center or at least i hope it's
now uh go with the message center and
you will have received a gift
that gift is a vw golf r um but it's not
just any normal vw golf r this is one
that has been adorned uh with a
beautiful livery uh created by
using some of our murals from thoughts
horizon five so you can get a little
taste of voice horizon five in forts
horizon four right now so go and get it
tommy bargains like i guess yeah tommy
well there you have it if you don't have
forts for iceland 4 you can actually go
download it from game pass right now if
you didn't already know so for tommy and
everyone else who does please keep an
eye on your in-game message center to
receive this beautiful moral art
inspired liveried car and unfortunately
that is all we have time for today so to
keep up with the latest forged horizon 5
news updates and details on more let's
go live streams by following the forza
horizon social channels and please stay
tuned to the forza channels tomorrow for
forza monthly for all the latest on the
forza universe thanks for tuning in
today see you next time as always
everyone adios
[Music]
you